[Music]
the marvelous red build tropic bird
these migratory birds spend most of
their lives at sea flying thousands of
kilometers across the atlantic and only
coming to land to breed
high up in the rocks they find holes to
make their nests
but not much else is known about their
habits
researchers from cape verde have only
recently found one of the largest
colonies in the world here on the island
of salomon
archway lopez is a field technician with
project biodiversity a local
organization trying to learn more about
the species to help save the birds from
threats linked to growing tourism they
monitor more than 500 nests on the
island
they are beautiful
they have like a big tail and they have
like it's like a woman
when they want to go out like you pay
the leaves and they paint the ice super
nice
today they're out tagging and taking
samples from the birds
they found an unwilling participant here
in the side of the cliff
the bird goes into a bag to help calm it
down
first they'll take blood to determine
its sex
it's like a we think it's from the feet
you can see like the vein is coming from
there to here
we clean it first and after we take it
the samples they collect help them
understand more about the birds habits
diet and migration patterns as well as
contaminants they've consumed
that also shows how the health of their
environments is changing
feathers also provide some clues
it's like i have to change it to check
like i when when is the
the time of the year like they change
the feather and to check like if they're
feeling well so
toxins build up in the feathers evidence
of how many pollutants the birds are
ingesting and therefore indicative of
the health of fish populations and our
oceans
of course there's also another way to
find out what they've been eating
after returning the bird home safely
it's time to check on other nests
this baby is just two weeks old the only
chick his parents will have this season
that makes the population especially
vulnerable and red-build tropic birds
are up against an increasingly dangerous
world
not far from their nests tourists soak
up the sun and sand
construction along the coast erodes
natural habitats and light pollution
disorients the seabirds during the night
introduce species like stray dogs prey
on the birds
not to mention plastic pollution which
gets into their diet through
microplastics in the fish they eat
but it's a balancing act tourism means
more economic opportunities for locals
on the island
but project biodiversity's co-director
says human activity is pushing seabird
colonies further and further away from
their breeding sites
one of the main problems that we have
with seabirds nowadays is loss of
habitat tourists they want to be
everywhere there are some developments
that are being planned to be
constricted on the on the protected
areas near the colonies so the problem
is the is bringing people close to the
colony we bring again
food waste which means stray dogs again
rats and etc
artur is back at the office preparing
samples to send to the university of
barcelona for processing where
researchers are discovering new insights
by crunching the data he's collected
the team hopes its findings will lay the
groundwork for saving the red-build
tropic bird and that by understanding
their fragile ecosystem we'll better
understand the health of our own worlds
you